ein gemälde das einen juden mit dracula
ziehen zeigt und mit ss-runen und
daneben ein schwein mit davidstern und
der aufschrift mossad auf dem helm da
ist keine kunst ist
antisemitismus übelster judenhass
ausgestellt bei uns in deutschland bei
der documenta also nicht im iran sondern
hier mitten unter uns deutschlands
wichtigste kunstveranstaltung ist dass
die die der bundespräsident sogar
persönlich eröffnet hat judenhass
ausgestellt und soll von der welt
bestaunt werden bild hat klartext
gesprochen und geschrieben unser
chefredakteur johannes boje er spricht
hier sehen wir dass kommentar heute in
der bild zeitung von einer schande für
unser land hier hängt dreck an der wand
schreibt er so widerlich dass man sich
übergeben möchte dass die worte die
klaren worte des bildschirms ja die
wenigstens eine reaktion gebracht haben
die dokumente hat diese angebliche kunst
nicht weggeschafft aber verhüllt schon
einmal auf das aktuelle gemälde wie es
dann verdeckt wurde durch einen großen
schwarzen vorhang verdeckt aber nicht
vergessen johannesburg bild chef bei uns
im studio damit ist die sache nicht was
der welt geschafft damit ist die sache
überhaupt nicht aus der welt geschafft
die verhüllung ist ja praktisch ein
nachdenklicher umgang mit etwas ja es
kann teilweise gezeigt werden teilweise
aber muss das überdeckt werden man denkt
sofort an debatten über kunstfreiheit
man denkt an einen klugen
differenzierten umgang mit verschiedenen
gemälden
all das ist es ja gar nicht es ist
knallharter antisemitismus hier wird ein
jude als schwein bezeichnet hier wird
israel in einer art und weise
verunglimpft die mit normaler kritik an
einem land nichts zu tun hat sondern die
einfach antisemitisch ist das ding hätte
abgehängt werden müssen mehr noch es
hätte niemals aufgehängt werden dürfen
und man wusste im vorfeld schon so viele
so viele stimmen haben gewarnt so viele
stimmen haben auch vor diesem
künstlerkollektiv gewarnt israel vorher
ausgeladen dürfte keine künstlerischen
beiträge zeigen ja genau also die
kulturstaatsministerin claudia roth sie
hätte es eigentlich besser wissen müssen
der bundespräsident der dawa und eine
für seine verhältnisse kritische rede
meint gehalten zu haben hätte es auch
besser wissen müssen ja meine güte man
muss sich eben mal damit befassen was
man in diesem land auf hängt sogar das
gilt im übrigen für jedes land
vielleicht vorher mal drauf gucken dann
passiert sowas auch nicht und patricia
du hast es ja gerade gesagt die
anzeichen waren ja da also wenn es schon
vorher wochenlang von guten und
wichtigen institutionen von experten
beim thema antisemitismus und ehrlich
gesagt auch einfach von jüdischer seite
schärfste kritik gibt sorge da muss ich
doch als kulturstaatsministerin claudia
roth oder als bundespräsident das sehr
ernst nehmen und sagen mensch da befasse
ich mich jetzt aber mal richtig damit
bevor ich das ding geöffnet bevor ich
das feiere und im fall von claudia roth
bevor ich es auch noch verteidiger vom
zentralrat kam die warnung vor der
ausstellung nicht als es schon passiert
war das hast du gerade angesprochen
johannes verlasse ist in die köpfe
versetzung von claudia roth von frank
walter steinmeier ja was passiert dann
möglicherweise in den köpfen ist das
desinteresse ist das völlige ignoranz
oder ist das möglicherweise sogar lust
daran genau die debatte jetzt zu führen
ich befürchte und ich sage es ungern
weil er ja schließlich der präsident ist
aber ich glaube bei frank walter
steinmeier ist es weitgehend unfähigkeit
hier muss man einfach sagen er hat ja
auch zum beispiel in die iranische
republik den terror stadt schlechthin
der israel vernichten möchte ein
glückwunsch telegramm geschickt von dem
er im nachhinein beweisen konnte oder
nahe legen konnte dass er das gar nicht
verschicken wollte das war praktisch in
versehen in seinem haus wo sowas
passiert da wundert ein gar nichts mehr
bei claudia roth ist die sache anders
gelagert ich glaube sie hat einen
durchaus intrinsisch in ihr drin
vorhandenes interesse daran die grenzen
so zu verschieben dass eben das worauf
wir uns mal geeinigt hatten dass es uns
sagt ba ist nämlich antisemitismus
judenhass dass das wieder mehr und mehr
gesagt werden kann man sieht es ja auch
bei claudia roth an anderen dingen die
sie so tut zum beispiel dass sie den
vertretern das eben schon erwähnten
iranischen mullah regimes die hand
schütteln dass sie wenn sie dort ist
sich ostentativ verschleiert also sie
leistet hier eine ideologie dem
judenhass nämlich von muslimischer und
auch linker seite vorschub in einer art
und weise dass ich mich gar nicht
gewundert habe dass sich ehrlich gesagt
niemand darüber wundern muss da daneben
so was raus kommt und dass wir dann
judenhass gemälde in deutschland in
kassel an auf auf großen wänden hängen
haben muss claudia roth zurück treten ja
meines erachtens nach hätte sie den job
nie kriegen können oder sollen denn mit
claudia roth ist es ja ein bisschen wie
mit der documenta selbst auch es gab ja
eine ganze menge anzeichen zuvor dann
hat man es trotzdem gemacht und jetzt im
nachhinein ist der schaden da genau so
ist es auch mit claudia roth wer ihre
karriere länger verfolgt hat weiß
einfach dass sie und ihr agieren im
kunst milieu auch dezidiert
antisemitischen und antiisraelischen
organisationen wie dieser so genannten
bds boykott da wärst man sessions
organisation also eine stark
antiisraelischen in teilen extrem
antisemitischen organisation immer
wieder vorschub geleistet hat das hat
claudia roth gemacht und jetzt ist sie
eben in dem amt muss man sich nicht
wundern dass so was passiert also klar
sie muss zurücktreten wird sie
vermutlich nicht sollte sie aber sie
hätte aber eigentlich gar niemals in
dieses amt gehievt werden dürfen